Cells are the champion escape artists,
able to squirm through narrow passages less than
one-quarter of their width.
Two new studies show that cells
don’t emerge unscathed from these feats of contortion.
A tight squeeze can burst the membrane
that surrounds the cell’s nucleus and damage its DNA.
Here, several cancer cells are slithering through
a miniature obstacle course.
When a cell has to struggle through a narrow passageway,
its nucleus pops, spilling the green marker into its body.
A leaky nucleus could be disastrous for a cell.
But the studies also show that
cells quickly repair the ruptures, allowing
them to return the green molecule to the nucleus
and prepare for the next tight squeeze.
This finding could open the way for a cancer treatment.
If this repair process could be blocked with a drug,
cancer cells might squeeze themselves to death.